The answer is 2/3 or 0.667, 1/3, and 0.
This is a mere matter of normalization.
If you add 1/3 and 1/6, there are 2/6 and 1/6. We get 3/6 which is 1/2.
These two things over here add up to 1/5.
To make them probabilities, we have to multiply everything by 2,
and we get those numbers of here.
What this suggests is by simple logic of the truth table door 1 has no a 2/3 chance of being correct.
Whereas door 2 has only a total of 1/3 probability of being correct.
Door 3, of course, because that's the one that Monty Hall lifted, has 0 chance of being correct.
That's actually a proof. There's an easier version of the proof, which is more intuitive.
It says before you saw the empty curtain
the chances were 1/3 each.
Once you see the empty curtain, you learn nothing.
The chance of the bet you placed is still 1/3.
Therefore, the chance that the other door must have gone to 2/3.
This is actually correct, but when I read this first, I didn't think it was plausible.
I really had to go through the truth table. Let's now go and program it.